all right whispering okay whispering
from original where'd you grow up fit
machine Michigan yeah Flint and Detroit
good you may leave Flint and how was
your family you grew up with both your
parents um yeah my parents my dad was a
good dude
I mean he's a good dude and he was real
family-oriented my mother on the other
hand was uh I don't even know what to
call her she hated her kids she really
did we there's four of us all together
and me and my brother she hated for some
reason she was just like vicious to us
and when like couple weeks my dad went
to prison because they were both junkies
but um my dad went to prison in like a
couple weeks before my 13th birthday my
mom started being nice to me right like
out of nowhere and got me uh Strout
using with her and didn't I know she
only did that because she wanted to sell
me to men so I would age at 12 I lost my
virginity to this dude named Danny door
he was a sexual predator I didn't find
out this till later
but when I had my first date with him
when I lost my virginity I remember and
he's the old man who likes 60-something
but err her and I he was like really
rough and he was like does it hurt and
he was smiling yeah like it was funny
right and I got paid five hundred for it
but he gave the money to my mother so
when I came out the bedroom after I got
the shower she's gone and then he trips
out time oh oh you can't be in here
you're underage you can't be in here
without your mother I'll get in trouble
so of course I get put out in like the
middle of winter the buses aren't
running
and I had to walk home so and I'm
already strong at this point so I going
home my mother is nowhere to be fine
thump and in two days later she comes
home with this dude that was covered in
hair him he was so gross they called him
tiny but he was like 400 pounds
she said if I wanted to get well I would
do this date with him so I was like well
let me get well first she said no do the
date and then you get well so she used
to like I don't know how to hit myself
so I had to depend on her a lot and then
of course she would want to fix first
and then not out trying to hit me it was
just all bad with her but that was the
only time she was nice to me is when I
was doing dates for her other than that
she basically hated us and didn't make
no apologies about doing it so when I
turned 15 my dad got out of prison and
found me in a dope house with my mother
and like straight week though he didn't
recognize me or how this makeup on I was
whoa
yeah Fatima had all this makeup on he
recognized me he just snatched my mother
up because my grandmother told him yeah
linda has Chrissy on door hi always
selling [ __ ] and strung out on heroin
and um I guess he down her choke down
his fork he was like what and she said
yeah you heard me
so 11 you went looking for us and that's
where he found this was the dope house
and he was in such a rage but my mother
he'd beat the [ __ ] out of her like in
the middle of the street she not getting
a whole side of her face rewired and her
arm was broken four places but when I
tried to stop him he didn't even
recognize me it's like Danny finally
realized who I was and kind of like
started crying and was like kept telling
me he was sorry to give him another
chance to be my dad so I told him yeah
little did I know I'd go home he was
forced to kick you know I was so mad at
him then it was like why are you gonna
let me be sick he was like
can't put poison in you so I stayed with
them for like two years and then almost
three and I came out to California
because my best friend / girlfriend had
a brother who had an escort service out
here and yellow pages of course I came
out here I met a lot of people I met one
of my regulars
oh okay probably better well he okay
delete that out but he was on my
regulars I mean I've met a lot of people
I did that for a few years of course I
relapsed and I came out here and after I
left the agency because he packed up and
went back to Michigan
of course I'm strong now again no family
effectiveness you know I
I moved from Michigan they um my
girlfriend's brother who had the escort
agency moved back to Michigan so it's
like now I have nobody out here by
myself
I'm strung out again and what do I do
I started putting ads and Aliexpress
somebody showed me how to do that and I
was working the streets in Hollywood of
course though it was not like I wasn't
familiar with it my mother showed me how
to work the streets back home this was
just easier to me I thought I mean I've
had a lot of bad situations happen like
you go park up on the hills or something
and then you realize there's another
dude laying down in the back seat you
know and then the guy tell you give him
his money back I've had guns fall I mean
I mean what haven't I had
[Music]
and they say whatever don't kill you
makes you stronger then I went to prison
I've been to prison four times for drugs
drugs possession of heroin now it's a
misdemeanor you get a ticket get let go
you know
did I do my first prison trip for drugs
I've seen a lot of [ __ ] in prison dude
that's a whole nother world people think
is like nothing it is something I mean
the CIO's are crooked and they do you
know of course they're crooked but it's
like I don't know how to explain it I
guess if you kissed a lot of ass you get
cool with the COS ending your life's a
lot easier and if you get in with some
lifers didn't you're like kind of
protected you don't have to worry about
really nothing just don't get in a dope
game or mess with anybody's girlfriend
that's the only thing that really causes
you any problem in prison just mind your
business I guess stay to yourself steady
your own business and it's easy you just
make it to your pro date if you have won
a lot of girls up there don't they don't
have one I met this girl named silly
[ __ ] double life she was 19 years old 11
one-year-old baby at home and now if um
she runs wants to go pun in the pen look
dude she's cool though and how long have
you been down here in ski ground Skid
Row
when I first moved out here I stayed in
the valley of course you know I was
working for escort service
I've been done on Skid Row since I was
21 well yeah
well do you know 43 I could show you
some pictures that would just blow you
and you'd be like no this is not you
you're kidding me yeah
like even just a few years back it's
like because I would had an apartment
for a while I was off the streets and
it's like I've been on the streets for
two years since I lost my Explorer and
um no my expedition it was expedition
says I lost my truck it's like been so
hard I lost my apartment my truck and
I've been out here for like two almost
three years and you could see the
difference I was looking at my picture I
was like god damn I look kid this is
like three years ago
yeah is it that rough when you get older
it's like it wears on you I guess a lot
more because when you're young you're
more resilient you know you're able to
bounce back better he's a tough life
hugger I think the word dude I've seen
some [ __ ] I mean come on dude digging
holes and put body parts places it's
like no I'm cool
do I go get the thick plastic you don't
like do I get it or do I just leave her
am I going to be putting the plastic too
because if you trip out and get scared
and they think you're scared do you
think you're gonna tell so you might end
up in that plastic with them you know so
what do you do act like everything's
going just do it you know that's some
funny way out [ __ ] what is your drug not
heroin yeah how I smoke crack deal they
helped so what'd you do for money now me
I hustle I sell dope you still take guys
no I haven't did I haven't dated thank
God in like two almost three years
that's a blessing
my homeboy form a team show me show me
that I had another skill selling drugs I
didn't know I could sell because I use
them you know but I I know everybody
that gets high so it's easy for me to
soak there's a lot of a lot of them want
to just kick it with me you know so I
said I I'm good at selling
I didn't know what that was a skill of
mine but like I was the only one working
for him for a long time and uh I made
home well a lot of money dude
I mean I owned 6900 right now but I had
I was pregnant and didn't know it I was
like seven months pregnant didn't know
it found out a week later I almost died
in the parking lot because I'm Rh
negative
I'm supposed to have a shot to carry her
full-term and my body extra like an
infection tries to border for some
reason she had kicked her placenta to
pieces she survived doctor don't know
how but she survived he said he'd seen
the placenta or the sack with the Terra
net he sent it detached from the uterus
but he has never seen it in chunks and I
guess it within hours started to spoil
immediately which made me septic it was
poisoning me and I don't know how she
survived all that she did though
and that's why I passed out in the
parking lot and they call the ambulance
and then I woke up two days later with
eyelids this thick swollen off my face
and tomorrow is septic poison they don't
know if I'm taking to the antibiotics
but it looked good and that my baby was
in the neonatal intensive care unit
fully developed seven months so that was
a blessing of course she was full of
drugs I didn't know I was pregnant um I
had my first son it 34 Jalen but I
finally sprint with him I got clean I've
got a method on did I supposed to do
brought him home only thing was I was up
scouting I had a pro warrant you know I
wasn't doing my pro right but I didn't
get busted til he was like a year old
and they bust me and take my son from me
and you have like six months
do your unification but anyways I lose
my son while I was in prison that was
like my first love how many kids do you
have two
yeah I waited a long time for him
he's gonna be kin
but I know is he with I don't know
somewhere out here
and then I have my daughter full of
drugs so I need try to fight for her I
was all [ __ ] up ahead and started
[ __ ] up with my snacks I name I would
sit outside the hospital and just smoke
and smoke that [ __ ] dope my own ways to
give me to $800 sex at a time so I [ __ ]
up like four times and that's sixty nine
hundred dude like wow but that's nothing
but a drop in the bucket compared to
what I made you hate to be up like eight
times a day that's sixteen hundred eight
times a day you do the math and you're
tripping over 6900 whatever that's why
he's having such a hard time now none of
his people who who make can make money
like I do even says to this day like
yeah that was my ace was who was my ace
but she [ __ ] up yeah I [ __ ] oh my
god
I guess it would be different I was
Victoria sucking his dick you know I
guess that would cause she'll is more
than I do and she's still working for
him but I'll suck his dick so I guess
that makes a difference and what do you
have planned for your future giving
sizes me I want to get clean but they
all say they're right everybody says
that everybody says it but bushes inside
I'm
P when I'm high I don't feel that him
enjoying myself I guess that's because
I've all I've ever known really you know
never been normal halfway normal when I
was pregnant with my son you know I got
my first apartment myself I mean I was
doing everything learned how to how to
get Ralph's for diapers you know the
Fidel our box of diapers I would have a
mess banana wait and I would buy the
wipes for four dollars so the $50 box of
diapers I was only paying like four
dollars in some sense food stamps for
bananas so when they skipped through
self checkout so when they scan the
receipt they see Huggies but it don't
say huggy wipes it just says Huggies
okay that's the box of Huggies okay and
they just scan your receipt yeah I
learned how to get all the expensive
[ __ ] as for what is it 40:11 banana wait
don't put that hook there they're gonna
stop it
yeah I hope so boy when I had my son I I
became a real hustler I sold everything
then asked everything take care of him
he was my first love
oh yeah when he was first born I had
like this overwhelming urge to smell him
it was so weird when they because I was
a scheduled c-section so they brought
him in to me and they had him all
wrapped up I said can you excuse me for
a minute till the nurse she stepped out
I don't reckon I said I don't know why I
feel like doing this but I snipped them
nice that was said I feel like a dog
right now but it was like this
overwhelming urge to get his scent I
don't know it was weird
I had to smell him smelled like every
part of his little body and kissed it
and I said hi I'm your mommy I'm the one
that's been talking to you he just
looked at me that was really cool that's
like one of the things always more I'll
never forget a scent I guess that's kind
of normal I mean every species
that's what they relate with your
younger cent you know I guess humans
aren't really that different because it
was weird it was just like this
overwhelming urge to sniff him so weird
I think it's weird parents what we do
but when I think about it's not weird
yeah he was something special dude he
was such a happy baby
he kept methadone for like two weeks
that was [ __ ] hell I didn't know he
was gonna kick like that he kicked bad I
was only on 70 milligrams - I started
off on one ting because I had such a bad
habit on heroin and I forced myself
brought myself down to 70 and I still
felt like [ __ ] but I didn't want him to
have a hard kick you know was it his
fault but I understand my mother I
understand how she could take her kids
she how can you hate your child dude I
was in love with my baby that was like
the happiest part of my life is when I
had my son my daughter is different I
mean I love my daughter but um I didn't
wait for her you know I didn't put down
the crack pipe in the needle for her I
did for my son I wanted to hold him more
than I wanted to get high you know I
wanted him in my life so I waited for
him and I had wait for him damn you're a
year you know how long nine months just
to wait for a kid it's a [ __ ] long
time dude I was so excited about him my
daughter I found was pregnant week later
I had her so there wasn't that bond I
have with my son
you know it's different I I could tell
you like the beginning to end with my
child at depth I remember one time my
mother beat my brother so bad she I
don't know why she hated us so much I
think it's because my dad loved us and
he paid a lot of attention to us my
brother was like six years you know he
was eight years old and she took this
belt and beat him from head to toe
he had these wells that came up off his
body that had split open purple wells
and I remember I grabbed the belt when
she went to swing again I said don't
touch him again don't hit him again with
that belt and she looked at me but I was
Tanner and you notice I was about as big
as her sounds like I was serious now I'm
used to you know fighting out there in
the streets with never kids I didn't
care I was seriously gonna beat her but
she would hit him again
but I think she knew I was serious
because she didn't she said get on my
face you little [ __ ]
I was like don't touch him and I picked
a garden by his hand and walked into the
bathroom and I was trying to put
peroxide on his little welts and I was
like man why does she hate us and then
my dad of course came home went to help
him with his pajamas and he screamed
piss it was stuck his shirt was stuck to
him of course she got slapped he slapped
her home I know because I went by the
register - listen you're hot back home
you had the registers you could see
through yeah I used to me and my brother
always used to spy on my parents like
when they were going there with all
their friends we knew where they were
getting ready to shoot dope still we go
in there and take a pencil and pushed
register open and be watching but I
guess what they be doing
with the needle kids are really smart
it's like I think back now like how
smart we were like we knew everything
that was going on with them you know
we knew when they were all out there
boiling water Amy my brother would do
this they're getting ready everybody
tell each other and he'd be like yo
they're getting ready to do it they're
boiling water now and that's sure enough
as soon as the water started to boil
they grabbed the pan and all of them
file into the bedroom kids are something
else
I heard whisper thank you so much for
talking to me you love them very
interesting story
you